because the titans were able to do a
deal with ryan tannehill they had a
franchise tag available and there was a
thought yesterday very very briefly that
maybe they would try to get derek henry
signed so they wouldn't have to use the
franchise tag on the running back and
they could tag jack conklin their right
tackle who's about to hit the market and
i think he's going to be the first guy
we here has agreed to terms with
somebody after noon eastern but henry
has been tagged so conklin will be free
your thoughts on the decision to apply
the franchise tag to derek henry
yeah well i think it's you know a
no-brainer you got to do it he's he's
just uh he's one of the most talented
offensive players in football with the
ball in his hand and then as we talked
about
you know
he just fits the mantra and the theme of
how the tennessee titans and mike frable
want to coach and play football so
not surprised by it at all i would
expect him to get franchise tagged and
you're right
the jack coughlin thing is going to be
very interesting i think there's a lot
of teams interested uh in in his talents
you know the big thing being
the right tackle market right now
of course in free agency is it's not
that special to me it comes down to
three names you know conklin
brian bulaga and maybe demar dotson the
free agent for the tampa bay buccaneers
those are the kind of the cream of the
crop at that position
as we stand here right now and conklin
is a lot younger than those other two
guys and in the prime of his career i
would honestly say i think laga
is a better player as of this second
over conklin
but i think you know bulaga's age and
has a little bit of an injury history
will therefore make conklin the number
one right tackle target on on free
agency and a guy where
you know mike i don't think the the
the uh what do i want to say the the
medical evaluation will be as important
with maybe some other guys he's had some
injuries but i think there's a type of
injuries that people will be able to
live with with the offense to tackle and
not have to uh have the most stringent
medical you know physical we've ever
seen
uh and uh again i think conklin is gonna
be one of the first guys to have that
deal he's represented by drew rosenhaus
who had a deal in place with trent brown
to jump from the patriots to the raiders
minutes into the negotiating period last
year i think history is going to repeat
itself unless the nfl presses pause or
maybe the teams press pause or at least
go a little more slowly because of this
reality everyone's trying to digest
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports